every generation there comes a show
which manages to change the entire
landscape of a medium akira mobile suits
gundam evangelion these are all examples
of shows that have changed anime forever
even more recently with instant classics
like school days boku no pico and corey
in the house that have captured the
hearts of a generation but have you ever
wondered what it was that inspired such
masterpieces to be made in the first
place yes today i will be looking at the
cultural phenomenon that is
bible black beeble black was an anime
produced by studio ghibli and directed
by hideyakiano before his depression
days it was a direct slice novel
adaptation of the then popular minecamp
franchise by little-known japanese
author adolf hitler so what is it that
makes beeble black the classic that it
is
some may say it's all the ass [__]
gangbangs retractable dicks and golden
showers
but what really matters is how timeless
the piece is even for a show that came
out years ago a testament to how well
it's aged it's just how ahead of its
time it is when dealing with social
issues especially for any of you young
budding college students who have no
idea about how to deal with rape and
consent there are many prime examples of
how you should properly and maturely
deal with consent with a fellow teenager
not anymore inspires students to take
action to help reduce sexual assault
what are you doing i want a [__] take
it easy take it easy
luckily the series makes it easy to
figure out what is and isn't acceptable
by emphasizing how serious the
characters react to the idea of rape he
told her he loved her and and began to
rape her oh this is so bad story-wise it
revolves around the troubles of teenage
romance and how to deal with your urges
as you hit puberty this may sound like a
typical high school story but it manages
to weave in a supernatural plot that
always keeps things fresh and as you can
imagine all these elements lead to many
romantic conclusions with scenes of
people making love
and kids if you don't know what love
making is it's when a man gets so
excited at the sight of a woman that he
sticks his penis inside her and pees of
course you'll find through watching this
show that sometimes more than one man
can get excited from seeing the same
woman and in which case they can just
pee on her leg pee on her face pee on
her stomach there's just
god there's just there's just pee
everywhere the writing in the show is
phenomenal taking obvious literary
inspiration from authors like harper lee
and oscar wilde that reflect on deep
philosophical issues such as taboo
religion and getting semen spunked on
you from five different directions a
brilliant example of this is when imari
utters the line it's none of your
business don't ask you've got rice on
your face the line is so out of place
and random in the context of the
conversation that it forces you to think
deeper why did she say that for what
purpose you've got rice on your face
mina say the main character clearly does
not have rice on his face so what is the
series trying to tell us
what does the rice mean what does the
rice say
what is
rice
could it be that the main character had
been eating lunch and had some rice
stuck on his face that the animators
forgot to put on or could it be a social
political reference to all the rice
fields burned during the vietnam war
you've got once on your face at this
moment we can only speculate not to
mention the deep and elaborate literary
genius depicted on such lines such as i
only think of holding your dick can be
easily compared to sun tzu's the art of
war the various styles of writing can
create the most vivid imagery that can
only be talked about as some sort of
incredible artistry your mind has made
up on its own countless times i had to
ask myself
am i really not in the show right now
getting pissed in my mouth it seems so
real and raw it's hard not to be stuck
in the moment the writing and dialogue
has become such a stable on the medium
that it still has an influence on modern
anime to this day go on [__]
i wanna come now
okay
in terms of voice acting both the
english and japanese dub have their own
selling point if you're an anime
connoisseur dining on only the purest of
japanese dialect then rest assured that
the original dub is the greatest piece
of voice acting since the japanese dub
of league legends
but where the series really shines and
how i recommend you view it is with the
english dub
why the show was so innovative that it
was the first ever anime to pioneer an
entire genre change when you switch to
languages changing from an engaging
character piece to an oddball comedy
through a combination of engrossing
dialogue and fantastic voice
performances it delivers a package that
somehow transcends the usual genre of
comedy maybe it's the way they capture
emotion so perfectly what's the matter
you don't want to [__] me or maybe it's
the way that everyone permanently sounds
confused trying to speak english we now
say hi all in all it's almost as if some
of these lines were delivered so
purposely bad and off points that it
makes you want to kill yourself stop i'm
i'm joking guys suicide is not a joke
it's it's it's a serious it's a serious
problem that many people deal with and
we shouldn't make fun of it so we
shouldn't be joking about it because
it's not funny except for this because
this is [__] hilarious
oh my god what happened there's been a
suicide somebody took from that building
what the [__] is she doing be serious
you dumb girl i've heard some people say
that they have a slight problem with the
fan service in the show and i mean
i don't know i don't really see it one
minute people will complain about boobs
being too big that they distract from
the story and then the next moment you
suddenly can't show five dudes jerking
off on a girl while she's being plowed
in the ass by three other dudes cause
it's sexually explicit overall beeble
black is a timeless piece about the
struggles of romance intertwined with an
original supernatural promise that has
something for everyone being a romance
drama supernatural erotica comedy if
you'd like to view this masterpiece then
be sure to stream it on crunchyroll you
can also go to
crunchyroll.com too oh hold on a second
i'm being told that this is not
available in crunchyroll
no idea why if you enjoyed bibble black
and want to see more then you'd might
like kill a kill as both gave me
erections while watching it and also
clan ad after story as you'll need a
tissue after watching both shows but as
always i've been gigguk i hope you've
enjoyed the review and i shall see you
all next time you've got rice on your
face
[Music]
you